this episode is brought to you by
blockfy blockfy is building a bridge
between cryptocurrencies and traditional
financial and wealth management products
they're creating innovative products to
advance the digital asset ecosystem for
both individual and institutional
investors and its platform now manages
more than 12 billion in assets full
disclosure i became excited enough about
this company that i ended up becoming an
investor but moving on block fi that's
block fi offers a wide spectrum of
services and i'll mention just a few
here first their blockfy rewards visa
signature credit card provides an easy
way to earn more bitcoin because you can
earn 3.5 percent in bitcoin back on all
purchases in your first three months and
1.5 percent forever after with no annual
fee second block file also its clients
that would be you easily buy or sell
cryptocurrencies including but not
limited to they have a wide selection
bitcoin ether litecoin and pax g as well
as usd that's united states dollars
based stable coins including usdc gusd
and pax blockfy aggregates liquidity to
offer seamless trade execution and
pricing blockfy also offers instant ach
so you can move funds onto the platform
and immediately start trading on their
platform you will soon be able to trade
with ach meaning you'll be able to buy
cryptocurrencies directly with your bank
account and there's a lot more coming so
check it out for a limited time you can
earn a crypto bonus of 15 to hundred and
fifty dollars in value again for a
limited time you can earn a crypto bonus
of fifteen dollars to two hundred fifty
dollars in value when you open a new
account get started today at blockfy.com
tim and use code tim at sign up that's
blockfi.com
tim and code tim
this episode is brought to you by
theragun i have two theraguns and they
are worth their weight in gold i've been
using them every single day whether
you're an elite athlete or just a
regular person trying to get through
your day muscle pain and muscle tension
are real things that's why i use the
theragun i use it at night i use it
after workouts it is a handheld
percussive therapy device that releases
your deepest muscle tension so for
instance at night i might use it on the
bottom of my feet it's helped with my
plantar fasciitis i will
have my girlfriend use it up and down
the middle of my back and i'll use it on
her it's an easy way for us to actually
trade massages in effect and you can
think of it in fact as massage
reinvented on some level helps with
performance helps with recovery helps
with just getting your back to feel
better before bed after you've been
sitting for way too many hours i love
this thing
and the all-new gen 4 theragun has a
proprietary brushless motor that is
surprisingly quiet it's easy to use and
about as quiet as an electric toothbrush
it's pretty astonishing you really have
to feel the theragun's signature power
amplitude and effectiveness to believe
it it's one of my favorite gadgets in my
house at this point so i encourage you
to check it out try theragun that's
thera
t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n there's no substitute
for the gen 4 theragon with an oled
screen that's oled for those wondering
that's organic light emitting diode
screen personalized theragon app an
incredible combination of quiet and
power and the gen fourth era guns start
at just 199 dollars i said i have two i
have the prime and i also have the pro
which is like the super cadillac version
my girlfriend loves these soft
attachments on that so try theragun for
30 days starting at only 199 dollars go
to thirdbody.com
tim right now and get your gen 4
theragun today one more time that's
thirdbody.comtim
h e r a b o d y dot com slash tim
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hand starts
shaking can i answer your personal
question
now what is
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show where it
is my job every episode to interview
world-class performers from different
disciplines to tease out the habits
lessons and so on that you can apply and
test in your own lives my guest today is
none other than sir james dyson sir
james dyson is the founder and chairman
of as you guessed it dyson through
investment in science and technology and
working alongside dyson's six thousand
that's six thousand you heard me
correctly engineers and scientists he
develops products that solve problems
ignored by others sir james was elected
a fellow of the royal society in 2015
and appointed to the order of merit in
the 2016 new year honors he was awarded
a cbe in 1996 and a night bachelor in
2007. james is the founder of james
dyson foundation inspiring the next
generation of engineers through
scholarships engineering workshops
university partnerships and the annual
james dyson award an international
student design competition in 2017 james
established the dyson institute of
engineering and technology where
undergraduate engineers pay zero tuition
and earn a full salary while completing
their degree studies and working on real
life projects alongside world experts in
dyson's global engineering research and
technology teams james is the author of
the brand new book invention subtitle a
life the story of how he came to be an
inventor himself and built dyson leading
it to become one of the most inventive
technology companies in the world james
welcome to the show oh
it's very nice to meet you tim and look
forward to our discussion
i have many questions and i i come to
this conversation as not just a a fan
and admirer but
consumer and user of your products i
have a dyson v11 animal about 40 feet
from where i'm sitting i have hot and
cool purifying fans throughout the house
because my girlfriend and i otherwise
fight over the central heating and
i want to cover some familiar ground
just to establish context for people but
we'll bounce around as i mentioned
before we started recording and i
thought we would start with a name and
to ask for some context and that name is
jeremy fry could you tell us
who jeremy fry was he was the sky of the
chocolate family the fries chocolate
family
but was an inventor in fact his father
who
worked in the fries chocolate family was
also a better inventor than he was
businessman but anyway so i don't think
their shares in fry's reverse very much
by the time they sold them but no jeremy
was an inventor and was the chairman and
founder of an engineering company
and i went to see him to ask him for
money actually because i'd done a
theater project which used the same
architectural roof system that he had
used in his own factory he'd pulled the
entire factory roof up by himself with
pulleys and ropes as a very light
aluminium structure sort of buckminster
fuller type structure
and i designed a
theater shaped like a mushroom for the
theatrical inversary of joan littlewood
and i knew he was a millionaire so i
wondered if he'd be interested in
funding it he's i'm not going to give
you any money at all but i can see
you're
an ambitious designer so why don't you
design some things for me that was when
i was still at college so i spent three
further years at college and then he
offered me a job
and i went to work for him
making and selling and designing a boat
that i had designed for him his
invention but i'd engineered it for him
over the years i only actually worked
for him for
about five years
and then i branched out on my own but i
came back and we had a joint company
together for a few years developing
a wheel boat a boat that went across the
water on its own wheels propelled and
floated by its own wheels and also we
did the vacuum cleaner together and a
very interesting wheelchair together
electric wheelchair
how old were you when you first
approached him for possible financing
which he rejected but what was the age i
guess you would have been i was 20 21
yes exactly 20 21
and what did you initially go to a
university to study
was it design and if it was designed
with uh within what
fields were you hoping to focus well
that's very interesting question i mean
i did classics at school that in greek
and ancient history but i also did art
and i of course i enjoyed art much more
than that in greek and ancient history
and i wondered if there was a career in
art so i went to art school as an
experiment more than anything else
in my first year
i discovered that there was this subject
called design
in the mid-60s 1965 design was not
something that was talked about or
publicized in the press or magazines and
there was no good design in shops either
so i didn't know what it was
and when i was told what it was it
intrigued me and i managed to get into
the royal college of art to study
furniture design actually i quickly
switched to architecture because i
thought it was more exciting and more
intellectually challenging that's not to
to put down furniture designers it's
just that it intrigued me more
so i spent
two years doing architecture
and that's how i came to do this but mr
fuller type building
and that's how i came to meet the
chairman of an engineering company and
that's what really turned me into an
amateur engineer i have to stress that i
am an amateur engineer i'm not a trained
engineer
but i hope i think like an engineer
let's dig into
that last statement because i think
there's probably a lot there what does
it mean to think like an engineer to you
whenever i look at anything i wonder how
it works
and then i wonder how it could work
better could i make it work better is
there a technology i could use is there
a way i can reconfigure it is a radical
breakthrough i could do for lateral
thinking that would make a huge
difference
i just think like that all the time
i mean it could be said to be rather
irritating to analyze
every single thing you look at and
sort of reject it because it's horrid or
it doesn't work very well but that's how
i'm built and that that's when i
realized that i should have been an
engineer i should have trained as an
engineer but that's all right i just did
it wrong way around that's all you know
i wasn't going to say it too early in
this conversation but james just imagine
what you could have done had you had a
formal engineering career that's a joke
i think you've done quite well so joe
but actually it's a serious point
because i have quite a number of
engineers who trained as an engineer and
then trained as designers
and i've got a few other like me who who
trained as designers and have them
become an engineer
and actually i can't do the calculations
that engineers do but i hope that i
think like an engineer and have the same
sort of enthusiasm and fascination and
curiosity
and that's what's really important
were those fostered in any memorable way
by your parents or by other people
when you were growing up when you were
in your younger formative
years
probably not because
my father died when i was nine and he
was in hospital from when i was six to
when i was nine
as i say i did classics at school so i
didn't spend any time really in the
physics labs or the chemistry labs
but i was interested in how things work
and i did take things apart and try to
put them back together again and i did
try to build
lighting systems and
and certainly when i was 18 i bought an
old car and had to learn how to repair
that
so i don't think it was something i was
really taught and if anything i'm an
auto diadect and not a not someone who's
ever taught anything and actually i
don't particularly like being taught
things i like to discover things rather
than be taught them
not a very cooperative person
that's probably one of your superpowers
i would imagine in a lot of respects at
least from what i've gleaned
if there are parents listening and i
somewhat selfishly ask this because i'm
planning on starting a family soon
but
is the way to
nurture
that curiosity through discovery through
projects like offering
kids the opportunity to disassemble
things and reassemble or simply
disassemble
do you have any thoughts related to how
to foster and nurture that perhaps not
by direct teaching but through other
other ways of approaching it
well yes i think learning by discovering
by failure by making mistakes
by being curious about things curious
the way you make things curious about
the way things work
to discover why some things work well
and some things work badly the thing
i've noticed with my children is that
they too don't really like being taught
things
they all learn by
empirically but self-discovery i mean i
i was just astonished to find i had lays
the mills at home in the workshop and i
turned around one day and there was my
14 year old son working the lathe i
never taught him
and he's gone through his life like that
and my son who's a musician has taught
himself to play all
all the instruments he plays that flute
the piano and the
guitar and has taught himself how to how
to work all of all the systems the
recording systems
you know i think it's the best way to
learn it's the most exciting way to
learn
and a lot of it is failure of course and
i did want to call my book a life of
failure
because
you know that that's
it's failure is exciting and you learn
from failure if you're taught something
and then
what you do works
you haven't really learnt anything
you haven't learned what doesn't work
which is usually more interesting what
you have a long illustrious
cv full of
successes but the connective tissue
would seem to be
hundreds or thousands of what some
people might consider failures i suspect
you view them perhaps slightly
differently but could you tell us the
genesis story
of the vacuum if you wouldn't mind
sharing the
origin story i think that would be a
good jumping off point for a lot of
other questions
yes well now when i was young the only
machine we had at home it was very you
know but didn't really have no money
when i grew up was a vacuum cleaner it's
an old-fashioned upright vacuum cleaner
with a huge pillowcase on the back you
know this sort of thing
i just remember as i was made to clean
the house with it by my mother i just
remember the horrible smell of stale dog
and stale dust
it not picking things up and then having
to go outside and shake the bag out
and then
you know restarting the machine and it's
still not working very well so i just
remembered that from my childhood and
then when i was
like you starting a family and had a
wife and so on
i bought one of these a second hand one
of these
uh original type of vacuum cleaners with
a pillow case on the back hanging off of
that
the same experience so i thought well
there must be a more modern version so
we went just the shots with my wife and
we bought what was allegedly the most
powerful vacuum cleaner in the world and
it was a canister model that sits on the
ground you don't push it along like a
lawnmower you pull it around with a hose
and it had paper bags it advanced from
pillowcases to paper bags and i had
experienced the same thing you know it
wasn't picking things up it was smelling
of nasty stale dog and stale dust i
wasn't picking things up so i couldn't
find a replacement bag
because i assumed the bag was full so i
went down and tipped the
contents into the garbage can
and gaffer taped or scotch taped it the
end back up again
so i had an empty bag
it's not a bag full it's an empty bag
and i put it back in the vacuum cleaner
and still no suction
and i thought wait a minute wait a
minute what's this all about
i was told that when the bag is full you
have to change the bag what i'm
discovering is that an empty bag
has no suction
i so i thought about it being
someone with an engineering bent and the
penny dropped
that all the airflow had to go through
the bag the bag wasn't a depository
where the dust went
the bag is a filter
and the very first dust that goes into
the bag whether it's a pillowcase or a
cloth bag
clogs the bag the dust goes straight for
those holes because the dust wants to
get out it's taken there by the airflow
when the holes are blocked the airflow
is blocked
so you lose your suction
so i went down to the shops and bought a
replacement bag put it in the machine
and had very good suction to begin with
and then it rapidly tailed off as i
vacuumed
so i
i thought well this is crazy you know if
you buy a light bulb it's supposed to
give you 100 watts well that's more
difficult now with leds but it's
supposed to give you 100 watts and it
gives you the 100 watts till it goes pop
you get 100 performance what you're
getting with this vacuum cleaner is a
heavily reducing performance this is
awful i'm annoyed i'm angry
anyway so my anger was simmering within
me
until i was installing a dry powder
coating
machinery huge machine to spray my
wheelbarrow frames because i was making
the ball bearer a wheelbarrow at the
time
and we used a cloth filter to trap the
powder that missed the frames it was
sucked away with a giant
fan
but every hour the cloth clogged
and you had to shut down the whole
machine
shake off the cloth and put the cloth
back up again and i asked around in the
industry what
intelligent people used and they said oh
they use a cyclone to collect the dust
not that filter thing you've got that
cloth thing you've got
so i got a quote for one and it was a
huge amount of money simply couldn't
afford it so i decided to build one over
a couple of weekends it's 30 foot high
and the chimney at the top stuck through
the factory roof and we collected the
dust in a plastic bag at the bottom of
the cyclone
and the machine ran beautifully all day
long without ever clogging and we
collected the dust at the bottom and
reused it
then of course i connected it this
clogging filter with the clogging bag in
the vacuum cleaner and i wonder why
can't you use a little version of what
the 30 foot high one what about a one
foot high one what's that going to be
like so i rushed home and made a
cardboard version of this huge one
it was only a foot high
and put it onto the back of my upright
vacuum cleaner because i'd kept the
upright one
and pushed it around and it appeared to
work so i always say that was the first
vacuum cleaner that doesn't lose suction
i didn't know the efficacy i didn't know
how well it collected the fine dust all
i knew was that it was collecting the
dog hairs and
the dust that was on the floor
that's really the genesis of it
now
from what i've read it was an immediate
success you licensed it to the world's
largest companies and henceforth amassed
this great fortune and influence is that
how it panned out oh i'm joking i wish
no what well no first of all
i offered the
idea to the ballpark company and they
weren't interested what they actually
said was which is something refrain that
i was to hear many many times over the
next few years look if there was a
better vacuum cleaner one of those big
vacuum cleaner companies would have done
it so we're not interested in it
so we had a parting of the ways and i
went to see jeremy frye my old mentor
and he agreed to back the development of
the vacuum cleaner
and so we had a 50 50 company and i was
able to devote my whole energies on my
own to developing the cyclone for use in
a vacuum cleaner i went around to see
there was an expert at port and down
which is a very famous chemical warfare
establishment in england the head of
that had written a book on filtration
devices cyclones electrostatic
precipitators and all that sort of thing
he said you'll never make it work in a
vacuum cleaner because cyclones are only
good down to 20 microns and as i knew
household dust is less than one micron
down to you know half a micron or even
less
so that was an interesting challenge
so i went back home and there are some
formulae for making successful cyclones
and i got my old maths teacher who
happened to be the husband of my
godmother to help me with the first mass
to work out the
the formulae so i went through all five
of the serious formulae and i got five
different answers
i thought this is no use i've got to do
this empirically i've got to develop
this myself
so i started the process of developing a
cyclone that would work
down to half a micron or less
and that took
5126 prototypes
failures before i got the
5127th which worked
it sounds tedious but it was the
complete opposite it was absolutely
fascinating day after day building maybe
one cyclone a day and testing it for i
was testing it for dust capture the
ability to capture retain the dust and
also for the airflow through the cycling
because i didn't want to want it to be
too restrictive
it was fascinating and you know do an
experiment and sometimes i it would get
better sometimes it would get worse
but because i only made one change at a
time
i knew exactly what it was that had made
it better or exactly what it was that
made it worse
so it's a process of learning by
experimentation
and you know it wasn't enjoyable every
day because failures are
not enjoyable necessarily and i'd come
home in the evening covered with dust
and
tell poor dedrick what what had happened
that day
and she tried to stay interested as we
were getting more and more into debt and
it took you know three or four years it
was a it was a long it was a long
long haul
how did you pay the bills during that
time keep the lights on at home while
you were
going through these many many many
iterations
jeremy fry my partner as it were had put
up 50 of the money and i had sold a bit
of land i had a veg my vegetable garden
very productive vegetable garden to
build a house on it
so between us we had about 60 000 pounds
i think it was and that saw us through
three or four years
and then i started getting into debt
now i never thought to ask this but
since you said one change at a time
this begets a question for me because i
think in the minds of many they might
hear 5000 plus designs
each one is totally different and you've
tried five thousand plus different
things so to speak sort of holistically
speaking but my question is
since you were changing one variable at
a time making one tweak and then
assessing whether it improved or
degraded the quality and performance
did you in advance have
say a hundred tests or
200 or 500 that you knew you were going
to run in the process of not doing
multivariate testing but sort of
changing one small component at a time
or were you testing one and then
deciding
on the next four or five i'm just
curious if there was a plan in advance a
schedule of some type for
the things you're going to test such
that i know this is a long question you
knew that you weren't going to do two
designs and win
the final outcome it was going to take a
period of time and many many iterations
does that question make any sense yeah
i've absolutely got it i'll answer it in
a totally different way the the perfect
invention and it's not about being
brilliant
it's about being logical and persistent
if you try and do a shortcut and say oh
if i did it like this with a
pipe this diameter and a length here and
something here and thing there it's
going to work it's going to be brilliant
it's going to work i know it'll work
and you do that and it doesn't work
you don't know which of those elements
that you incorporated has caused a
problem
so you have to start right at the
beginning with the most basic most
simple thing
and then
make one change and see what effect that
has
if you make two changes you don't know
which
worked or which didn't work you don't
know anything about it you only know
it's performance you don't know why
so you you must only do one change at a
time
now
there can be brilliance in knowing what
that one change might be
but although it's tempting to say well
you know i wanted to try different
lengths i want to try different angles i
want to try different diameter pipes
going in and out i want to try
multi-entries
you know there's lots of things i wanted
to do
but i had to start right at the
beginning and just go one step at a time
you know every single time you try and
jump to the solution it doesn't work
and you've got lost so you have to go
back to concrete solid ground
where you know the result of
what you've done that change you made
i have a question about perseverance
because the many people listening will
hear
the story
and
wonder
how and why you continued but i want to
add a little bit of nuance
to that
just by observing
that you have
prototyped designed produced
and shipped many many different products
over the years
some have worked out some haven't i'm
sure
many behind closed doors ultimately were
stopped they were abandoned in some form
or fashion because they weren't viable
in this particular case
why did you persist
had you done some back of the envelope
calculations and determined hey we have
very we have 60 000 pound downside here
the upside i think could be tremendous
therefore this is worth three to four
years of my time and if it gets to six
i'm gonna cut my losses how did you
think about that what compelled you to
continue because you're clearly a very
smart guy you wouldn't just be pounding
your head against a brick wall at the
end of a dead end
i'd love to hear you comment on that
yes i suppose at the beginning i thought
it might take me a year at the most
and not as many as 5 000 prototypes
ever the optimist
i thought we might
it would be easier than it was and that
that's always true with every
development it's always much much harder
you know i do i still run actually do
long distance running i have this thing
called everybody knows about the pain
barrier there's a point three quarters
of the way through the race where it's
really starting to hurt and you can't
see the end
and you want to give up
and you go through that process with
every invention with every
technology breakthrough
and it looks brilliant at the end
because
from where you started and where you've
ended up there's such a difference
there's such a big leap
and it's different to anything that's
gone before so it looks like an act of
brilliance
but it wasn't
it was just hard work and it always
takes four times as long as you think it
will and it always costs more money
i mean fortunately most research and
development
until you start using really expensive
machinery it's mostly human effort
and of course i was putting my humid
effort into it which didn't cost very
much
so over the four years i did get into
debt in the end i'm in huge debt in the
end but
what kept me going
was that i was making progress and i was
convinced that it was the way vacuum
cleaners should be vacuum cleaners
shouldn't lose suction
it's deeply disappointing
and unsatisfactory that they lose
suction and lose efficacy you know want
to get the housework done quickly and
get all that pesky dust up you don't
want to leave it behind
so i was convinced that
well i was pretty certain that if i can
make it work
people would be interested in it i
didn't know i mean i was just assuming
that but like me they would be annoyed
but they're losing performances is
unsatisfactory so it was partly
that i could see it would make a good
product and partly i wanted to solve the
problem how do you capture this dust how
do you get separate dust from air
without having a clogging filter in the
way it was a really interesting problem
not for anyone else but it was an
interesting problem for me to solve
particularly as i've been told it would
never work
that always eggs me on i was going to
say that seems to be the best way to
motivate you and
did you have
this is a full-time
occupation or were you doing other
things
simultaneously
or
did you have in mind in the back of your
head a plan b if this weren't to turn
out
i had no plan b it had to work i was
pinning everything on it
betting the house literally because i
had to put the house up as collateral to
the banknote
and i didn't know it would work
but i just hope that i can make it work
and i was going across the yard every
day to my the equivalent of my garage
it's actually a coach house but it's the
old-fashioned equivalent of a garage
working there on my own for two or three
years
so you you finally
you summit everest
i'm gonna mix all sorts of metaphors
here and you have the
the new and improved mousetrap does the
world beat a path to your door what
happens what unfolds after that point
you know i had
previously run
a very successful company making
high-speed lending craft
and my partner had run a very successful
engineering company making valve
actuators so we both decided we were
inventors
and designers
are not commercial people so uh uh what
we decided to do was develop technology
not commercialize it so our intention
was to go out and license it
and so i spent well i suppose about six
years that's slightly longer trying to
license the technology
and no one was beating a path to my door
i was beating a path to their doors
likely people
and they pretty well all turned me down
in fact all of them
all of them turned me down some started
and gave up
but otherwise
total non-acceptance it's interesting
because i suppose i should have given up
then i mean if if the commercial people
didn't think it was worth doing why
should i think it's worth doing
the more people to turn me down the more
excited i got because
why were they turning it down
well they're probably turning it down
because they rather like selling bags
and mine didn't have a bag and they made
a lot of money so you know the razor
blade syndrome partly because of that
but i also
i really
noticed that they weren't interested in
changing their technology they wanted to
stick with what they had it's what i
call a commodity product it's not very
exciting product they're not skis or
surfboards or
anything interesting and vacuum cleaners
were a commodity product in which no one
had any interest so i could sort of see
why
they weren't bothering
because consumers weren't really
bothering you know it's that thing with
a bag that
sucks you know
but i i saw it differently
you know you use it every day
it makes a noise it's supposed to do
an efficient job of getting rid of dust
which is nasty stuff
and keeping it inside the machine
and getting up dog hairs and all the
awful things if it doesn't do that
properly your life is not as pleasant
i saw it as a very important thing you
know it's a it's a mundane
product it's a apparently boring product
but i thought we should make it
interesting it's an important product
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance i recommended it
in fact in the 4-hour body this is more
than 10 years ago and i did not get paid
to do so with approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient-dense and
comprehensive formula on the market it
has multivitamins multi-mineral greens
complex probiotics and prebiotics for
gut health and immunity formula
digestive enzymes adaptogens and much
more i usually take it once or twice a
day just to make sure i've covered my
bases if i miss anything i'm not aware
of of course i focus on nutrient-dense
meals to begin with that's the basis but
athletic greens makes it easy to get a
lot of nutrition when whole foods aren't
readily available from travel packets i
always have them in my bag when i'm
zipping around right now athletic greens
is giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
the razer blade mention
makes me think of one of my friends
who's one of the most successful venture
capital investors in silicon valley and
one of his
guiding i don't want to say theses
that'll make it a bit
too highfalutin but one of his
heuristics is looking for startups
that for every dollar of revenue they
generate take away ten dollars of
revenue from some incumbent
and
so i can see why they would not want to
replace their
was continuity
revenue or business model with your
technology when did you
finally feel
that you were at an inflection point or
had
gained a a handhold with commercial
i suppose
confirmation in any way
i mean i i did have one or two licensees
who did start to produce vacuum cleaners
some gave up
one in japan continued
but by well it was actually
10 or 11 years after i first started
developing cyclonic technology i
realized i changed the business plan
instead of trying to license people i
was fed up with license agreements the
difficulty of licensing people that i
was becoming a lawyer
dealing with license agreements not an
engineer developing technology
i thought well look these competitors
clearly don't want
to develop new technology they don't
want to bring out a product with a
difference i'm going to do it myself i
didn't want to have to be a manufacturer
and
someone commercializing it but i'm going
to do it because
i really believe in it
so
put your money where your mouth is dyson
and do it
we were three engineers at the time
and we decided we were going to the
business making vacuum cleaners we had
no factory no money
nothing we just crammed together in our
coach house with a machine shop
underneath
so a couple of quick questions you
believed in it now one could imagine
there's some
now in this case it wasn't supposed
fallacy but sunk cost fallacy you're so
invested in this that you really want to
see it to the end
did you also
have
consumer feedback or feedback from
friends who had used prototypes
that confirmed your
belief
in the product was there some type of
market feedback that also
contributed to that
belief in continuing i think my friends
all thought i was mad and
reducing myself and my family into
penury but
no unfortunately not by the way i bought
out my partner by this point because
he'd got fed up with all the failed
licensees
and his financial advisors advised him
to get out there there was no future in
it
so i bought him out he must tell that
story over some stiff drinks these days
man
or at least he used to it's a very
friendly passing and uh i quite
understood it you know the vacuum
cleaner wasn't his life it was my life
not his life so i bought him out
for 45 000 pounds and uh and i was on my
own
and in many ways actually i mean he was
a huge help he was my mentor
a great friend and a wonderful designer
and engineer i felt a bit lonely going
off without him but on the other hand it
actually made me feel better being
completely on my own it suited me
but i had no idea that whether anyone
wanted to buy this product no idea at
all i hadn't done any market research
and you can't really go and ask someone
whether they want to buy a vacuum
cleaner that doesn't have a bag
it's got a strange cyclone instead and
it's got this automatic hose that comes
off the back
you can't get a straight answer to that
it's too easy to think that you can go
and ask people whether your product is
going to be successful
it makes me think of the henry ford
quote which i'm paraphrasing but if you
ask people what they wanted they would
have said a faster horse you know
something along those lines and
exactly the whole point is you've got to
back your own instincts
you can't get help on this you've got to
take the risk and sometimes you're going
to be okay and sometimes you're not
that's just life's like that and
in a way that's what makes it exciting
that's what makes it difficult
yes certainly it's living on the knife
age you don't know
so did you have any difficult
conversations with your wife at the time
and if so how were those navigated how
did you
approach those my wife was wonderful
there were no difficult conversations
she believed in it
and she's an artist and
was wonderfully supportive but she
understands the need for a project
and to create something they need to
create the need to have a project
so she never once complained or they
were incredibly short of money
had to grow our own vegetables and she
made our clothes and she was
hard-working and wonderfully supportive
there were never any difficult
conversations even
when we went along to the bank with a
lawyer to sign endless guarantee forms
putting the house on the line every
penny we had on the line
wow well i hope i'm very lucky sainthood
is in her wikipedia entry yes
the retail shop surveys and so on i as i
understand please fact check this it
showed that people didn't want to see
their dirt this dust dog hairs etc
that the vacuum cleaners bins should not
be see-through so why did you decide to
design
in the way that you did
when we went to see the retailers to try
and sell the vacuum views the retailers
of course most of them refused to stock
it because it was strange looking
you could see the dust
and who on earth is dyson
you're not hoover or electrolux or a big
brand
so we're not interested in you
so
we
as engineers we liked seeing the dust it
was incredibly satisfying and fun you
know if you push the machine around on
the floor
making a noise
and you could see the dust collecting in
the bin
if it's going to bag you can't see that
you're doing anything and of course i
would say you're not doing much but of
course
but at least you can see what you're
doing and you know you you pick up
interesting things
although dirt is disgusting it's also
quite fascinating so we thought seeing
the result of your endeavors was an
important part of the process
but nobody else did and the retailers
certainly didn't want
their customers to see the dirt
however one or two brave retailers did
take it on
and curiously enough seeing the dirt was
the very thing that customers wanted to
have they wanted that
that fun that excitement that
satisfaction if you know
so again this is what you're really
asking about is market research is it
worth doing can you learn from it
and the answer is not much and you
certainly can't rely on it
so again you have to you have to back
yourself you have to back your own
judgment
it's not a science
you have to believe you're right and
back it and
hopefully you're right more times than
you're wrong with those few
intrepid retailers who are willing to
take a risk i'm wondering what their
risk was did they actually buy from you
at wholesale
and then stock did they take them on
consignment or some type of other
arrangement
and
what was the pricing of your vacuum
compared to
others in the stores
yeah that's a very interesting question
well i'll do it in pounds but the
comparison works for dollars i mean we
were selling ours at just under 200
pounds whereas most vacuum cleaners were
50 pounds so we were three to four times
the price of everybody else
i think the retailers didn't take it
because it looked different
and because
we weren't a brand
the one or two who did take it were mail
order catalog companies they were our
first customers
they're not the the most high brow
of retailers they're quite low brown
which is a very interesting thing
actually because what what i discovered
and
life has confirmed it since
is that the richer you are the less
interested you are in vacuuming
the poorer you are the more important
vacuuming is to you
probably the more house proud you are
because you actually do the vacuuming
so i think there's an assumption that
because the vacuum cleaner is expensive
it's bought by people with money
and whilst that might be true there's
also a great deal of interest and people
who don't have much money and it's a
very important purchase for them
that's fascinating interestingly it's
recession-proof if you it's a recession
you stop having expensive holidays
and instead you think more about your
home
and of course during the pandemic that's
been utterly true that if you're
confined at home good filtration in your
home good vacuuming is very very
important
do you remember the terms of the deal
with those retailers were you drop
shipping were they taking inventory on
and then giving you you know net 200
terms well i decided in my own
simplistic terms that they should put
their money where their mouth is so they
should buy for stock we've never ever
done consignment never done that no you
need a retailer who believes as you
believe
who's backing your idea and who's
putting effort and money and care into
it
so most people i think would describe
dyson or in their minds i see dyson as a
premium brand this is in some cases
probably in almost all cases an
expensive relatively expensive
brand
i've read a quote of yours which is and
again please feel free to fact check
can't trust everything you read on the
internet i don't design down to a price
so i would just love to hear
how you think about
finding and solving problems picking
your problems
and then when you go into product
development
how you approach it if price is not
one of the determining factors
or a primary determining factor there
are people who designed to a price
and i absolutely see that there's
probably a huge market for that and
that's a perfectly valid thing to do but
i want to design something that works
really well
and that lasts and uses new technology
and improves the performance all the
time that's what i'm after
it's not those that i don't care about
cost or price i really care about cost
or price but i want to incorporate the
technology that makes it work well
or does a job more efficiently or uses
less electricity whatever it is
and often of course new technology for
example we've developed new technology
high speed motors
but they cost four times as much as the
old motor
but they're much more efficient much
lighter use less electricity and use
fewer materials
so it is the future
but initially they cost four times the
price
we've now got them down a bit so they're
about twice the price
so i'm not
trying to do
a cheap product i'm trying to do a
product that works very well and
advances that genre from a technology
point of view
who are some
actually before i get to who are some
you already mentioned i think one
figure who may have been influential in
your thinking buckminster fuller
for those who don't know that name you
can google bucky balls geodesic domes
tensegrity these are some terms that
will take you down the rabbit hole of
buckminster fuller
who is akio morita akio morita and
what did you appreciate about him
the wonderful thing about just one story
which really
says a lot about him think of the
walkman
and how that has changed everybody's
life
but his company didn't want to do the
walkman because it wouldn't record i
mean up until
1982 or whatever it was a tape recorder
was a tape recorder it did recordings
ekko marisa bought out a tape recorder
that didn't record
it played back only
and his own company thought it was
completely mad
that's brilliance you know that that
takes balls to to say
i'm going to bring out a product that
doesn't do what people think it's going
to do but it's going to enlighten their
lives
and has it
enlightened their lives it's
extraordinary the i
part almost the iphone almost
everything's come from mp3 players
they've all come from that one idea that
you want to play back
are there any other inventors designers
engineers who
stood out to you when you were
developing your chops or who really
stand out to you currently maybe one in
the same
i always admired citroen not as citron
are now but as they used to be
when they developed new technology
hydro-pneumatic suspension
with a hydraulic system that did the
steering the brakes and the suspension
or four-wheel
suspension interconnected suspension
and an aerodynamic car i mean they they
were 50 60 years ahead of the rest of
the car industry so i enormously admired
them
sony of course who developed wonderful
technology
developed the first well not actually
they got the lithium-ion technology from
oxford university but first
commercialized and produced
lithium-ion batteries it's only had a
whole string of technology developments
their name
equally admired
mr honda
of honda
not because necessarily he did brilliant
inventions but because he was the master
of iterative improvement he was never
satisfied he was always making maybe
little changes at a time
but in the end all those little changes
added up to quantum leap so honda i mean
a honda lawnmower was the first
lawnmower i ever had which always
started first time
even after the winter with the old
petrol from the previous season left in
it i could guarantee and i used to bet
people then i'll go over there and one
pull on the cord and it'll start
so i admire honda for a slightly
different reason
he makes what they look like big
inventions but they're not they're
iterative improvements and that's
something to never forget you must never
be satisfied
always be dissatisfied always be unhappy
about your product keep on making it
better and better
it's a life of unhappiness
and then i've got frank whittle who
developed the jet engine and that's a
great story
because no one believed in him
he wrote the theory of the jet engine in
a sort of child's exercise book
when he was at cranfield university he
was an raf fitter actually he used to
make models left school when he was 15.
went through uh was got into cranfield
and then went to cambridge
and while he was at cambridge he got a
first class
his first most tripos as well as built
the world's first jet engine
and i've
never seen an engineer get things right
first time like he did
we've in fact got one of his one of the
very first engines he did
it's called a welland
and i bought it off someone the
enthusiast who had done it had found it
and they've done it up
but it never worked very well the fuel
system didn't work
and my engineers discovered that the
fuel system was a rolls-royce system not
a whittle design system
so we rebuilt the fuel system from
whittle's drawings
and it worked perfectly and it works
perfectly every time whereas the
rolls-royce one didn't
so so i've got huge huge admiration for
him i mean that was an extraordinary
development i mean turning an engine
that had 12 000 moving parts you know
the spitfire engine the air engines at
the time had all these moving parts were
hugely vulnerable
had to have cooling and you know one
bullet through the cooling pipe and
planes had it dives and the pilot has to
bail out so
he turned it into one moving part
it's just brilliance breathtaking
brilliance
it's very elegant very very elegant now
actually it's as good as segway as any i
recall the first time i used the
airblade and
please
forgive me if this is simplistic and
please correct me if i'm getting this
description wrong but where the
air is acting like a blade almost like a
squeegee on a windshield pulling the
water off of your hands as opposed to
trying to evaporate it and i think
everyone's had the experience of using
these sort of gas station bathroom or
airport bathroom
drying devices that feel like a kitten
farting on your hand i mean they do
nothing so you just end up wiping it all
over your hair or your clothing or
something like that
how did you
pick that as a product category
was it just one of 600 that you tried
within dyson and it was the one that
happened to work could you walk us
through the process
of developing the air blade
we were
trying to use air blades
which is a very
sharp blade of air
for another project
and it wasn't quite good enough for what
i can't tell you what the project is
it's top secret but it wasn't quite good
enough for what we were doing
but we noticed as you ran it across your
hand it rippled your skin
so we chucked water on our hands and saw
that just scraped as you said like just
like a squeegee but it's not physical
it's it's just air
just like a squeegee so we thought well
i make a great hand dryer and of course
we looked at hand dryers and how they
work is they have a three kilowatt i
mean a three kilowatt heater as well as
a vacuum blower
that can clean a motor blower
so they're three and a half thousand
watts
very expensive to run whereas our blade
was only costing us 700 watts
and what's more
the thing about the hot air is it chaps
your hands it's trying to as you said
evaporate the water turn the water on
your hands into steam which is very
expensive process
and it takes a long time
and also it leaves your hands chapped
it removes the oils from your skin
as do paper towels
we thought well this makes a really good
hand dryer
so we made a hand dryer
it so happened that this was our the
first application of the new technology
motor we're developing so we developed a
major that went 120 000 rpm
instead of the normal 30 000 rpm
120 000 rpm by the way is very fast i
mean a jet engine is 15 000 rpm
and a formula one engine is about 19 000
at maximum
we were taking electric motors from 30
000 up to 120 000
and in a hand dryer not not a
sophisticated product in a hand dryer
and a vacuum cleaner
it gave us great airflow and great
pressure
and pressure was important for this
airblade
was that the first
product and i simply don't know was that
the first product that was sold to
i don't know if this is the right term
but industrial
clients as opposed to
end user individuals or had you already
developed a sales channel for that type
of product no not at all we didn't do a
business plan and by the way i don't
think restaurant owners would like to be
called industrial partners but it it's
um
but yes they are quite right you're
quite right i'm i'm i'm teasing you're
quite right um no yes you know you're
right it's the first time we were not
sending to
to people at home and i mean to be to be
honest i i don't feel very comfortable
about that but i think it's a great
product
why don't you feel comfortable with that
because i i really want to make products
for people at home that we all use at
home the good thing is that we use them
in a railway station or an airport or
restaurant or wherever it is so at least
ordinary people use you know people like
us to use it
but i'm far happier when i'm dealing
direct with people at home and we're the
main value propositions for
these
industrial partners these these uh
customers whether they be airports
restaurants or otherwise
the energy costs and labor costs
associated with the device so they could
justify the higher up front
price by amortizing it over a relatively
short period of time and recouping
that that investment was that the basic
pitch or was there more to it well that
wasn't the basic pitch the basic pitch
was it's a very pleasant and quick way
to dry your hands
without the waste of paper
and without the excessive heat of hot
air hand dryers which are very slow
anyway and ineffective
and the wonderful thing about
our hand dryers is you never run out of
paper
i mean how many times you've gone to try
and get a paper out of a paper towel
holder and it's not there
and the other thing is it's quite
difficult to dry all your hands and dry
under your fingernails with a towel
whereas
ours does that
so it's hygienic it's quick
and it's reasonably pleasurable you're
not you're not damaging your hands
you're not taking the nice oils out of
your hands and you're getting on your
fingernails
it's slightly noisy we've got them a bit
quieter now
but actually
an architectural practice said they
liked the fact that it was noisy
because when one of their partners went
to the laboratory you could tell whether
they washed their hands or not but
that's great
the lie detection device and the hand
dryer all
you never know when harry's not going to
wash his hands you got to keep an eye
out for harry if he comes out
and you haven't heard the noise
keep away from him
so the air blade
at least from the outside looking in
seems to have been a huge success could
you share any of your favorite failures
and these are devices that actually made
it
out of the shop and into the real world
do you have any favorite failures what i
mean by that
is a device
that was not a commercial success but
that
offered many lessons or perhaps
learnings that led to
successes in other areas or later does
anything come to mind
we only really have one which is our
washing machine
but i i don't call it a failure
because i think it's a great washing
machine
but our mistake was to sell it too
cheaply we didn't charge enough for it
in the first place because it has two
drums and two drums two motors a clutch
and very big capacity in a small normal
size of washing machine
so it's very expensive to make
i mean more than double
the cost to make of an ordinary washing
machine but it was much better so it
could take a very big load
it washed very quickly with low
temperature water because it was
introducing proper action we discovered
that if you dried washing with your
hands
in just a few minutes you could wash
better than you could in a washing
machine in an hour and a half or however
long they take
we also discovered that cashmere shrinks
because of the time it's in the water
and the temperature of the water so if
you can do a low temperature wash and do
it quickly
and do it thoroughly
it's a better washing machine
so ours was much better at washing
than a conventional washing machine with
its action and we should have charged a
lot more for it
it's the uh one and only time i've ever
listened to the marketing department who
said if you if you charge less you will
sell more
actually we charged less and sold fewer
but we were losing so much money on each
one the board decided to stop it and
that was probably a mistake with
hindsight i mean we should have
put the price back up and carried on
with it it was a big project i mean a
washing machine and we were we're up
against people who have been waking
washing machines for years and years
with a much lower cost base
we were starting from scratch
with a high cost base
so
actually much the same
thinking occurred with the car at a much
later date the development of our car we
ran into the same sort of problem
different commercial
issues but the same sort of problem as a
startup in that business our costs were
so much higher
than an incumbent than the existing
competitors i mean i'm still using them
and everybody who bought one thinks it's
a much better washing machine it's very
disappointing we've stopped making it
but we lost a lot of money on it and it
was a commercial failure but a i think
an engineering success
in the case of
n526 the electric car
going into it i would imagine you were
aware that
compared to incumbents who had the
infrastructure in place distribution
channels etc that you would be
fighting an uphill battle with respect
to costs and and many other things per
unit prices etc
why did you decide to
pursue it going back to 2013 2014 when
we started
only tesla was bothering to produce
electric cars and they were in the very
early phase the rest of the industry was
taking no notice and all the projections
by the industry and by commentators were
that you know by 2030 only three percent
of global cars would be electric
so no one was bothering to change and
the incumbents you know had heavily
committed to
diesel and petrol engines and existing
technology
we thought well we're starting from
scratch we're not committed to anything
we can we can do what we like
rather as tesla has done
we've got a lot of very very clever and
international motor engineers
we're developing new technology
batteries
we do a lot with air treatment taking
out pollution heating it and cooling it
and that's really what a car is it's uh
it's electric motor it's batteries and
you've got to do a lot with air
efficiently very efficiently because
you've only got battery power so you
don't want to waste your battery on
heating or cooling
the car so we thought we were quite well
placed to do a car although we'd never
done one before no other manufacturers
were being interested in it
we knew that batteries were far more
expensive batteries plus electric motors
plus the electronics to control the
electric motors and the battery
management system it's far more
expensive than an internal combustion
engine
as tesla has proved actually
even with relatively small battery packs
a tesla is a very expensive car to make
however we saw that the lack of interest
from the
incumbents the rest of the motor
industry gave us an opportunity as which
indeed tesla has taken advantage of
and we thought that we could do one
that was at the top end
quite what the top end was we didn't
know back in 2014.
all that changed with dieselgate
when dieselgate happened in 2016 2017
and
those people making large quantities of
diesel engines got into real trouble
the way out of the trouble from a pr
point of view and i suppose by that
stage they saw which way the wind was
blowing
but
they had to get into
electric vehicles fast so they had to
spend a lot of money
completely turn their business around
upside down and produce electric
vehicles and that's fine well you know
that meant we would have had competition
we weren't particularly worried well
because one's always worried about
competition but we thought there would
still be space for us
but what was happening was that
the electrical vehicles they were
producing they were producing at a loss
not happy to do that they were able to
do that because they were sending across
their fleet they have to produce a
certain have certain knocks and socks
emissions so if they had a electric cart
when end producing none they could
produce gas-guzzling big suvs at the
other end on which they make a lot of
money but overall they were able to do
that without having to buy carbon
credits so i could see that we were
going to have to compete against people
who were making electric cars at a loss
and i don't want to get into tesla too
much but tesla earns quite a lot by
selling its carbon credits to other car
manufacturers
and they have well-heeled investors you
know they've been through 25 billion
dollars i don't have 25 billion dollars
i'm privately financed
because i have to make the money i i
spend on product development
i can't take that sort of risk
so by about 2018
2019 when we stopped it it became
apparent that it just simply wouldn't
work commercially
plus the fact that our costs coming back
to that point i made earlier about the
washing machine
our cost to make a car even without the
complications of the battery management
system batteries and so on
would be
you know 50 higher than a bmw or a
mercedes
carpet or a volkswagen car production
costs
so it was just too risky for us
we would have to charge aston martin's
style prices for a very good car with a
600 mile range and
you know quite a big car as well with
good off-road capability but
it was just too much of a risk
are there any
features
of the car
that you're particularly proud of or
that you
would hope to see in the world someday
at scale
curiously i was a friend of alex moulton
who did the first small wheel bicycle
with suspension don't you you know what
i mean
i don't know what you mean if you
wouldn't mind
he developed the mini with alex's
agonist one of the principles of the
mini was that it had very small wheels
the advantage of small wheels is that
they don't create a big wheel arch
inside the car
so you can make a very small car
where the wheel arches don't protrude
much into the car so there's room for
four big adults
and he carried on but you have to pump
the tires up harder because the wheel is
very small so he then developed a very
small wheeled bicycle called the molten
bicycle
which had very small wheels and you have
to pump the tires up incredibly hard
but to overcome the sort of the
harshness of the ride he put suspension
on it rubber suspension on it as in he
was also the person who developed the
suspension for the mini and i knew all
about that and he was a friend of mine
and i actually took the opposite view
that the car should have huge wheels
and the reason for that is that a large
wheel has less motion resistance
and so it's much more efficient and
that's efficiency for an electric car is
all important
so the ability to move along and and
have
the least resistance is what you want so
i discovered
the biggest wheel that you can make
that where you could replace the tire at
a tire
depot
because obviously you can't do a wheel
that you where you can't replace the
tire at a tire depot i discovered that
was what that was so our car had huge
wheels i mean they're nearly a meter in
diameter
they're huge
that was to reduce the motion resistance
but actually it gave a lot of unexpected
benefits
so it was better at road holding
it was a more comfortable car because of
it
you could
relative to the size of the at the hub
the center of the wheel you can actually
have quite a big tire
which made it comfortable
and because it had a relatively narrow
aspect ratio
it was better in snow
and mud
a fattar
is very slippery in snow
and mud
whereas a thin one has much more grip
and is less likely to aquaplane
and when it came to developing the
suspension and the road holding it also
turned out to be
excellent as well we had to develop a
special tyre for it
and again i mean we were very ambitious
we developed our own chassis
and if you know anything about making
cars the most expensive and important
part of a car is the chassis
we decided that we looked around and see
if there was any car companies chassis
that we could buy but none of them
fitted with our big wheels and spacing
apart our big wheels putting them on the
four corners of the vehicle there wasn't
a chassis like that so we had to develop
our own chassis
that was a development cost i didn't
mind that but um i mean tesla for
example didn't develop their own chassis
they went and bought a lotus one and in
fact lotus built their first chassis um
basic car initially
but we decided not to do that i did pile
on the cost of it but i think it made
ultimately a better car
i want to come back to privately held
privately held company this makes what
you do and what you've done all the more
interesting and impressive to me
i'm much more familiar with
the
venture-backed
startup
ecosystem and
the road map for such a company that
involves raising
in some cases as you mentioned billions
of dollars
of funding sometimes tens of billions
then going public and so on and so forth
have you ever
been tempted to
become anything other than privately
held
when i did the ballpark company i
borrowed money
and then because i couldn't pay it back
i got some investors in
so i became
a company i only have 30 percent of the
shares so there were other directors and
i found that an uncomfortable position
so when i started the vacuum cleaner
company i did go out to
venture capitalists they were called
then i mean it would now be called
private equity but they were called
venture capitalists
and i discovered that i was completely
useless at raising money so i hugely
admire people who can go to go to these
people and raise money i was hopeless at
it none of them would back me
it was during the you know the early 90s
during the big there was a really big
recession in the early 90s in many ways
much bigger recession the 2008 recession
and the banks had repossessed were
repossessing houses left right and
center i mean it was a really terrible
crash
i hadn't really approached a clearing
bank
which is my normal way of borrowing
money
what is a clearing bank a clearing bank
is a is we call them high street banks
so it's banks that lend to consumers
predominantly
so the one you'd find in a street
right where you can go and deposit money
and hopefully take some money
they got me left
yeah so in desperation i went to
the bank that i banked with
and
at first they said no
because i wanted to borrow about 400 000
pounds
which is quite a lot of money back in 19
early 90s
and my bank manager then appealed to the
ombudsman within the head office of the
bank
and he managed to persuade them to lend
me the money i had to put up the house
the security but this is a time when
they didn't want the houses to security
because they got themselves very
unpopular for tracking people out of
houses and they had a huge number of
houses on their books in fact my
particular bank became the state agent
in order to try and sell off the houses
that it had so i was absolutely shocked
and stunned when they agreed to lend me
the money when i cleared the debt and
relationship was on a more even basis
with the bank i did ask the bank manager
why he lent me the mummy and he said
well i went home and asked my wife what
she thought of a vacuum cleaner without
a bag and she said i hate bags
and he said i saw that you fought a very
long lawsuit in the united states i
could see you had determination so those
were the arguments i used within the
bank
it was actually really encouraging it's
a good bank story there are very few
good bank stories and this is one of
them
why did you find it uncomfortable
to take on investors and end up with 30
percent
of of the company what about that made
you uncomfortable
i didn't think it would make me
uncomfortable but it did
and the reason it made me uncomfortable
is that you are
if someone else has put money in and if
someone else has shares you have to
listen to them
well i i felt i had to listen to them
so you're not actually running the
company
you're sharing the running of the
company
and a lot of decisions will be decisions
that they want quite rightly because
they've put a lot of money into it
and so you spend a lot of your time
wondering about whether this latest idea
you have they'll approve of and you have
to go and get their permission and it
has to be done through the auspices of a
board meeting
i'd done that i was a director of a
public company selling the high-speed
landing craft that engineering company
then i had my own my own company i had a
30 share in it
and then finally i was in a position
where i could have my own company and
make my own decisions and during the
time that i'd been developing the
technology before i decided to go to
manufacturing and commercialize the
invention in the early 90s i actually
discovered i liked
relying on myself
rather than
having to be collegiate and share
decisions with somebody else
because it was all down to me and so the
whole risk was mine
i'd evaluate the risk myself and work it
out myself
and i just found that a
a much easier way for me to work
i'm not like that now i hasten to add
i've i've matured a bit
and now we do run the company on a
collegiate basis
but
in the beginning it was really important
and crucial to me that i was all the
decisions i was making on the fly
all the things i was making i was making
for me
because i thought it was the right thing
to do
that's quite a good way to approach
things anyway
i think
i hated
being part of a public company which i
was in my first job so i knew what that
was like
and the shareholders are always out of
tune
with what is actually happening in the
company not through any fault of their
own
but they can't see into the future like
we could
as employees of the company
meaning you had to at least i'm more
familiar with the us but
you
were
captive to the quarter by quarter
expectations of shareholders who could
not
did not have transparency into the
five or ten year plans of the company
itself is that what you mean pretty much
that i mean there's no reason why they
should believe
the gleam in our eye or that you know
the new technology new product we're
developing they look at what you're like
at the moment who you are and what
you're like at the moment and what
you're talking about in the future but
they it always seemed to be out of
kilter
when we were doing well the share price
was down and the share price
was up we were doing badly and it just
seemed to be out of kilter
again you know you're not on your own
you're not making decisions because you
believe they're the right decisions
you're making them for
sometimes other reasons
what it looks like transparently or
whatever you know or what shareholders
might think of it
so it's just much better to
be one-track minded
and just thinking entirely about the
product we develop and make products
that's what we do it's very in a sense
it's very simple thing that we do and
it's a product that's important it's not
who i am or what the company is or what
it looks like that's important is the
product going to excite people and do
the job properly
that's what matters that's all that
matters actually
it's not completely true because of
course employees matter enthusing
employees matter and looking after
employees all that matters
but for all of us who are working here
what really matters is that our product
works in the marketplace
i would imagine
also happy motivated employees and so on
talented employees
are in a sense a byproduct of good
products and then they further help to
create good products in the sense that a
lot of these things cascade down from a
product focus
and
you have had a tremendous
just a tremendous run and certainly if
many more things ahead of you
how did you decide to
commit your energies to
your new book invention a life
this is certainly a commitment of time
and energy how did you decide
to focus your energies at least in part
on that
partly because
i just wish there were more engineers i
just wish that more young people would
find engineering fascinating interesting
and worthwhile
and i think it's particularly true now
because
everybody's talking about global warming
and we're just talking about using fewer
resources recyclability and all these
sort of things using less energy less
water
and it's engineers that can make that
happen
so engineers can make the world a clean
world a world using less energy while
using fewer resources in a world
recycling things engineers and
scientists can solve those problems but
the pity is that school children
and even people at university don't
realize that
we would rather talk about it and do
something about it and
i think that's a great shame
so
i do think that a lot of people think
engineering's hard and difficult that
science is hard and difficult
and of course perhaps it is but it's
also very creative and they people don't
don't see that either
um so if if i could somehow show through
the book
that a stupid person like me a person
who's not academically successful and is
is not brilliant at all
through really caring about products
caring about technology caring about
engineering
can produce products that save energy
that use fewer resources and that work
better
hopefully to
achieve what young people want to
achieve now and young people want these
things they want
cures for horrible diseases like
alzheimer's and cancer
they want products that use less energy
that
generate electricity in a clever way if
i could show that that i as a simple
person not having done classics at
school could turn my hand to doing some
of those things
that maybe
other people would think that
engineering wasn't this difficult hard
thing that seemed impossible when you
look at something like the walkman or an
iphone or
some extent dyson vacuum cleaner
it's inaccessible
to young people and products are
becoming more and more inaccessible
as a school child you look at an iphone
or
in any piece of clever technology a jet
engine or whatever it is
you don't know how it works and you
don't believe that you could ever design
one of those or design a better one
but actually you can you really can and
that's what i wanted this book to try
and show
that
it is young people who will solve
today's and tomorrow's problems and we
can solve them by the way without having
to make life miserable for all of us
it isn't just
the few people who want to who
are attracted to engineering who can do
it
many more of us can do it
if we can be motivated to do so and if
we can overcome this
feeling that it's impossible and that we
don't understand it
there's almost a an inverse snobbery
about technology there's almost a pride
that i don't know how to hang a picture
or
mend a car whatever it is
it's almost a mark of intellectual
superiority
whereas i think the obverse i think it's
a
it's a mark of lack of intellectual
curiosity
not to be able to take something to bits
and mend it or not be able to perform a
you know mental washing machine or
dishwasher whatever it is i think it's a
shame that you're not interested in
doing in solving that problem and
repairing it
that's really what the book is about
and the timing is because
we
i've been promoting the lack of
engineers for many years and of
continuously going to the government
saying you know we're not producing
enough engineers were not produced until
finally the the minister in charge of
education said well start your own
university stop complaining and start
your own university
and he was bringing through a bill
through the houses of parliament which
allowed anyone
not anyone but someone who was able to
and with the necessary resources and so
on to start their own university
so i took on the challenge of starting
our own university and the reason i did
it was that we almost exclusively
recruit graduates at dyson and that's
what i've always done because i believe
in
recruiting people with enthusiasm
lack of knowledge lack of experience
people who are not afraid to make
mistakes not not afraid to try a new
path
so we've been recruiting all these
graduates here in many years why not
recruit undergraduates
and i only did it because well because
of that because we have a very young
corpus anyway but also because we we
cover a very broad field of engineering
i mean everything from mechanical
engineering right through to software
and robotics and artificial intelligence
so we have a huge number of disciplines
here
and i wouldn't have done it if we were
had a very narrow field but because our
field was so broad i felt we could offer
the students a good experience
just for clarity this is the dyson
institute of engineering and technology
yes yes which has by the way just got
university status so we'll shortly be
calling ourselves university we've won
university status
i was also horrified actually that the
amount of money young people have to
borrow in order to go to university for
living expenses and the fees they have
to pay so at the very point in their
life when they want to get married and
buy a car and buy a house and live
normally they're saddled with this huge
debt
so i could see that our students
i would pay them
i would pay for their education
they would work for me
for part of the time
and they would have the excitement of
practicing what they're learning in
theory
and learning from what i think the best
scientists in the world best engineers
in the world at dyson they would have
wonderful mentors wonderful
hands not academic lecturers at
university they would have hands-on
battery development scientists electric
motors scientists software people
artificial robotics people all these
people are here
and they can talk to them and learn from
them and experience all those fields and
decide
much more knowledge what they want to do
and in fact half of them are becoming
software engineers because
you know the world needs so many
software engineers and they find
software fascinating and the others want
to do mechanical engineering or
electrical engineering it's actually
been a very happy experiment i've
thoroughly enjoyed it and i think the
students have as well
so the timing of the book is because
sorry this is a really long story it's
our first
yeah we it's a four-year course and our
first year has just graduated and the
graduation ceremony will be in september
so i wanted the book to come out at that
time
and the theme of the book is really that
you don't have to be an expert
and in fact experts are often unhelpful
you have to have enthusiasm curiosity a
thirst for knowledge
and determination and those are the
things that will solve all the world's
problems
well i'm very
excited on multiple fronts to see what
you what the university what this book
does and as you just said
i think it will
foster
all of those things you just mentioned
including the book will foster
more engineers it will encourage more
people to embrace engineering but above
and beyond that it will help people
through your stories through your
lessons learned
through the principles reflected in the
book to think like an engineer and to
become more curious ask better questions
even if they don't have
even if they will never have any formal
engineering training that's certainly
true for me i didn't study classics but
i majored in east asian studies which
has about as much application to
engineering as wood classics
and
still in the process of preparing for
this conversation
and reading more about you looking at
the book
was struck by just how
cross-disciplinary and how adaptable
many of the principles are in the book
to include and not exclude also those
people who might look at themselves as
hopeless liberal arts majors or
something along those lines
so i'm excited for it i always think the
best questions are naive questions
which is why i love employing students
or graduates and students because they
start you off on a different train
because the trouble with experience is
you know how to do things well i mean
you you know how to do some things and
experience is a baggage that can get in
the way
and what you need is someone saying why
why is it like that why do you have to
do it like that
and it stops you dead in your tracks
and you so it forces you to not follow
the path that everybody else follows
students and graduates have no fear
of pioneering they've got they've got
nothing to lose
[Laughter]
one thing i hope that we encourage here
is that failure is not
not a failure and if you go on doing the
same thing and making the same mistake
that's not a good idea that you know
failing once or twice
in the on trying to do one thing is okay
nothing wrong with that we all learn
from that
you know i don't think they teach that
enough at school
or at university for that matter
i mean at cambridge for example they
didn't have a machine shop and an
assembly shop where the students could
do their own projects
they didn't have that it was all
theoretical
but actually we gave cambridge some
money and to build a workshop so that
the students could build their ideas
through building things
using your hands actually building your
prototypes i mean we our engineers at
dyson build their own prototypes they
build their own test rigs
and it's through that building of the
test rig and the prototype don't give it
to someone else to build to an assistant
to build you can build it yourself and
it's through the building the prototype
and the testing it yourself
that of course you see you experience
the failure but you learn how you might
change it and improve it
that's what i saw you see through my
5127 prototypes each prototype i built
myself and tested myself
and it was through that total
involvement
that my brain started to think how do i
solve that problem how do i solve that
problem
and that funny enough it's the actual
making it with your own hands
is terribly important
and you know we were given hands and a
brain and you should use both at the
same time what's wrong with that
it's not that using your hands is not a
lowly activity
it's a
it's useful
man's always done yes
yeah i can't recall the exact expression
but how
our tools shape us and that's only true
or i suppose it's always true but it
means that perhaps you should use a tool
other than a keyboard sometimes yes very
much so very much so
but we're all slaves to it aren't we
well i am extremely excited about
the book everyone again the book is
invention subtitle a life
and i have one more question before we
go
before we wrap up this first
conversation and sometimes this question
is a dead end and i'll take the blame
for that if it is but i like to ask it
nonetheless and that is
if you had a billboard metaphorically
speaking on which you could put any
quote could be yours someone else's any
phrase
word image question anything at all
to impart
a message to many people
what might you put on that billboard
well i'd probably put two messages
one is there's nothing wrong in always
being dissatisfied
always look for improvement and the the
other is drop your fear of failure don't
be afraid of failure
so i'm am i allowed to build those
you are allowed to build
[Music]
i hope we haven't gone down a dead end
go for a bit that we go down and do that
well
you know i guess that would be on theme
we could have just asked another
question i could have changed that
question and asked it again and iterated
uh but we happened to get it right the
first time like the like the jet engine
which is an incredible story i've never
heard that before and uh what an
enjoyable conversation i really
appreciate you taking the time today
thank you very much really good
questions enjoyable
and perhaps someday
we'll get to see you in person across
the pond but in the meantime i wish you
tremendous luck with
everything that you're engaged with
which is a lot including launch of the
book everyone
should check it out invention
subtitle life
sir james dyson thank you again for
taking the time and being so thoughtful
in your answers really think people will
benefit from this and
to everyone listening we will have show
notes
with links to all resources all people
everything mentioned in this episode as
usual at
tim.blog podcast and
until next time
get your hands dirty experiment often
ask why why why and thank you for tuning
in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every friday that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that i've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the uh the world of the esoteric as i
do it could include favorite articles
that i've read and that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just a little tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four-hour
workweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in your email and you will get
the very next one and if you sign up i
hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
theragun i have two theraguns and they
are worth their weight in gold i've been
using them every single day whether
you're an elite athlete or just a
regular person trying to get through
your day muscle pain and muscle tension
are real things that's why i use the
theragun i use it at night i use it
after workouts it is a handheld
percussive therapy device that releases
your deepest muscle tension so for
instance at night i might use it on the
bottom of my feet it's helped with my
plantar fasciitis i will have my
girlfriend use it up and down the middle
of my back and i'll use it on her it's
an easy way for us to actually trade
massages in effect and you can think of
it in fact as massage reinvented on some
level helps with performance helps with
recovery helps with just getting your
back to feel better before bed
after you've been sitting for way too
many hours i love this thing
and the all-new gen 4 theragun has a
proprietary brushless motor that is
surprisingly quiet it's easy to use and
about as quiet as an electric toothbrush
it's pretty astonishing you really have
to feel the theragun's signature power
amplitude and effectiveness to believe
it it's one of my favorite gadgets in my
house at this point so i encourage you
to check it out try theragun that's
thera
t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n there's no substitute
for the gen 4 theragon with an oled
screen that's oled for those wondering
that's organic light emitting diode
screen personalized theragun app an
incredible combination of quiet and
power and the gen 4 era guns start at
just 199 i said i have two i have the
prime
and i also have the pro which is like
the super cadillac version my girlfriend
loves these soft attachments on that so
try theragun for 30 days starting at
only 199
go to therabody.com
tim right now and get your gen 4
theragun today one more time that's
thoroughbody.com tim
[Music]
b o t-h-e-r-a-b-o-d y dot com slash tim
this episode is brought to you by block
five blockify is building a bridge
between cryptocurrencies and traditional
financial and wealth management products
they're creating innovative products to
advance the digital asset ecosystem for
both individual and institutional
investors and its platform now manages
more than 12 billion in assets full
disclosure i became excited enough about
this company that i ended up becoming an
investor but moving on block five that's
block fi offers a wide spectrum of
services and i'll mention just a few
here first their block by rewards visa
signature credit card provides an easy
way to earn more bitcoin because you can
earn 3.5 percent in bitcoin back on all
purchases in your first three months and
one point five percent forever after
with no annual fee second block by also
its clients that would be you easily buy
or sell cryptocurrencies including but
not limited to they have a wide
selection bitcoin ether litecoin and pax
g as well as usd that's united states
dollars based stable coins including
usdc gusd and pax blockfy aggregates
liquidity to offer seamless trade
execution and pricing blockfy also
offers instant ach so you can move funds
onto the platform and immediately start
trading on their platform you will soon
be able to trade with the ach meaning
you'll be able to buy cryptocurrencies
directly with your bank account and
there's a lot more coming so check it
out for a limited time you can earn a
crypto bonus of fifteen to two hundred
and fifty dollars in value and for a
limited time you can earn a crypto bonus
of fifteen dollars to two hundred fifty
dollars in value when you open a new
account get started today at blockfy.com
tim and use code tim at signup that's
blockfi.comockfi.com
tim and code tim
[Applause]
you